[Musique]
notre invité a longtemps été votre
invité dans votre salon chez vous peut
être en famille devant la télé pendant
26 ans elle à égayer vos soirées elle
vous a donné le sourire ou vous a ému en
incarnant un personnage solaire haut en
couleurs bruyant même dans une famille
formidable qu'elle fidèles de la série
n'a pas rêvé d'en faire partie de cette
famille et d'avoir notre invité comme
soeur comme maire ou comme belle-mère un
rôle qui lui allait comme un gant mais
un rôle qui a peut-être été un peu
encombrant car sa vie d'actrice a
commencé bien avant avec les plus grands
jean luc godard pierre richard alain
resnais sydney pollack francis veber et
tellement d'autres des rôles elle en a
joué des dizaines au cinéma à la
télévision et bien sûr au théâtre du
classique du moderne du confidentiel du
populaire mais qu'est ce que notre
invitée n'a pas joué quel texte quel
style quel rôle manque à son répertoire
on va lui poser ses questions bienvenue
dans un monde un regard bienvenue anny
duperey merci d'être avec nous ici au
dôme tournon du sénat c'est vrai ça quel
rôle auriez vous aimé jouer et quel rôle
ne vous at-on jamais proposé alors je je
je viens d'en tourner un pur qui va être
pour la 2e ou la 3e fois ils savent pas
encore un unitaire un film voilà qui va
être un peu un peu qui commence un peu
comme un chabrol et qui termine comme un
hitchcock où je fais une folle
machiavélique et c'est ce qui manquait à
votre répertoire s'il veut ma vie parce
que j'en ai j'ai joué des inquiétantes
aussi comme ça j'aime bien sortir mon
oeil qui n'aime rien ni personne mais
mais là j'avais pas vraiment fait ce
point là vraiment ça veut dire que vous
aurez tout fait tout ce que vous
souhaitiez faire non j'ai pris moi je
souhaitais rien c'est ça qui est bien
n'attendez pas spécialement voilà c'est
ça pas trop pas de projection de soi
dans l'avenir c'est tout à fait patent
pas trop de rêve non plus enfin je rêve
bien sûr mais des de vision idéale de
soi comme ça comme j'ai pas j'ai devenue
comédienne j pas par hasard mais je
tends l'avoir vraiment rêver c'est très
pratique parce qu'on n'est pas jaloux
les choses vous viennent on aime les
faire mais comme on n'a pas de grandes
choses dont on rêve on n'est pas déçu
ses très pratique vous n'avez jamais eu
envie d'écrire un rôle pour vous même
non
non pas pas vraiment si j'en ai écrit un
j'ai écrit un seul scénario j'ai écrit
le premier scénario de bernard giraudeau
qui se disent se lamentait en disant
j'ai 40 ans je n'ai jamais faire un film
x hydra et josé giovanni effectivement
d'aller donner le livre de sa soeur qui
s'appelait la face de l'ogre et et nous
avons fait ensemble avec bernard son
premier film et c'était mots mon unique
scénario votre scénario je parlais du
rôle peut-être un peu encombrant de
catherine beaumont dans une famille
formidable est ce qu'il a été est-ce
qu'il a un peu éclipsé tout le reste y
street et en comblant ce nom il a pas
été encombrants d'abord parce que c'est
très curieux les gens ne m'ont jamais
appelé catherine les gens qui était fan
de la série
je dois dire que ma petite fille étant
tombé dedans
on regarde pas on regarde jamais ce qu
on a fait je veux dire on le fait et
puis voilà on ne sort pas ce pas les dvd
et seulement trois petites filles est
tombé dedans effectivement j'ai eu droit
cet été en voilà il ya un épisode qu'est
la revue six fois c'est vous dire voilà
dès qu'elle vient chez moi boom elle se
précipite sur les trucs c'est vrai que
je vous avoue que rob revoyant
jeu pas tous mais certains épisodes
certaines scènes comme ça je lui disais
qu'est-ce que c'était bien
qu'est ce qui était bien c'était bien la
série c'est bien ce qu'on a fait donc
c'est pas spécialement encombrants pas
ce que c'est ça une place tellement à
part dans ma vie dans la vie des gens et
même dans l' objet télévisuel était
était
était tout à fait miraculeux quelque
part j'ai toujours dit c'était un cadeau
de la vie et du métier voilà il ya une
alchimie particulière avec cette série
même une sorte de miracle
je n'exclus pas une intervention
miraculeuse de qui de peut-être je ne
sais pas parce que la manière dont c'est
arrivé je vais encore le raconter parce
que c'est tellement beau j'étais en
train de finir d'écrire le voile noir à
propos de la mort de mes parents et gt
gt sur la fin vraiment en train de
coucher des dernières pages avoir fait
remonter vers dans toute cette douleur
de ce traumatisme
je pleurais tout le temps et j'ai
demandé à mon agent de me trouver une
comédie pour me remonter le moral est au
mois d'août je m'appelle et me dit à des
écoutes tu voulais une comédie y en a
trois
trois fois une heure et demie en magie
vu l'état aux suisses faudra bien ça
et elle me dit ça commence tout de suite
et là j'ai dit ah non non non non non
parce que j'ai promis de rendre mon
texte le 15 septembre au plus tard je
suis dans les pages les plus durs je ne
peux pas lâcher elle me dit t'as de la
chance ça commence le 16 ça ne s'arrête
pas là puisque je rencontre joël santoni
qu m'explique qu'il n'a jamais rien fait
de drôles de sa vie qui a fait plutôt
des films lourds dramatique je rigole je
lui dise que je suis en train de faire
est vraiment mais en quatre cinq phrases
on découvre qu'on est orphelin de père
et de mère tous les deux au même âge
alors là c'est vrai que moi qui ne
croient pas en dieu me qui croît au
mystère j'ai fait on regarde le ciel
n'en sait pas où ils sont trop bien
organisée
c'est vrai que c'est ces partis sous ses
auspices là et ça va vraiment très bien
est ce que c'est un peu la famille dont
vous aviez rêvé est ce que c'est je
pense que c'est sage je pense j'ai pensé
hardiment au bout de quelques années que
l'amour vraiment il n'ya pas d'autre mot
l'amour que les gens avaient pour cette
série tenet peut-être au fait qu' ils
ont senti que pour au moins deux des
créateurs joël santoni et moi il y avait
une c'était pas des télécoms les autres
quoi il y avait une nécessité de se
créer une famille tribales comme on
aurait aimé en avoir et on avait un
avantage en fait joël et moi c'est que
hante encore phelim aux gens ayant subi
des choses dures
on a on avait une qualité qui n'est pas
donné à tout le monde c'est à dire qu'on
peut passer
du tragique au nez de clown très vite ce
qu'on a toujours fait ça l'effet de
rugby et donner le change comme ça et
est en fait c'est un mélange des genres
qu'on a fait qu'on a concocté ensemble
qui est pas courant son reste dans la
comédie soit on est dans le sensible
mais mélanger les deux comme dans la vie
comme ça c'était ne vous avez transformé
ce malheur on était une force l avant 20
ans c'était pas forcément écrit ce
destin d'actrice vous l'avez déjà un peu
dit il n'y avait pas de comédien dans
votre entourage en normandie comment ça
arrive dans votre vie à quel moment où
vous dites je tenterais bien cette vie
d'actrice j'ai eu l'énorme chance d'être
élevée après la mort de mes parents par
une tante magnifique était la soeur de
mon père qui avait été une enfant une
fille sacrifiée
c'est à dire qu'elle rêvait de devenir
professeur de faire des grandes études
elle était extrêmement doué et comme ma
grand mère veuve deux fois élevé trois
enfants tout seuls ma tante a été
sorti de l'école à 11 ans
pour servir au bistrot que tenait ma
grand-mère pour permettre de garçons de
faire des études et je crois que comme
ma tante m'a pris en charge ella ella
j'ai été sa revanche quoi c'est à dire
elle a dit celle là celle là fera tout
ce pour quoi elle est douée donc à 11
ans elle a vu que j'étais très doué pour
le dessin j'avais la peinture j'avais
tout ce que je voulais elle m'a inscrite
aux cours du soir des beaux-arts à 11
ans déjà à rouen et puis je lisais
j'écrivais j'avais tous les livres que
je voulais enfin voila l a été c'était
une femme qui était qui a été
merveilleuse mais vous allez quitter
écoles tovo aussi avant 16 ans oui j'ai
eu un gros malheurs scolaires aux baous
à 14 ans et demi ouais mais à mon époque
on pouvait quand on était victime comme
ça d'une sorte de mahler scolaire
inintégrables quoi c'est un petit peu
normal je pense parce que quand on a
trouvé ses parents morts à huit ans et
demi l'enfant célèbre elle est foutue
donc on est très difficilement mélange à
bhl avec des gamins
il ya en plus le sort m'a donné 15 cm de
plus qu'une
différence de plus ravi c'est vraiment
plus voilà donc c'était c'était vraiment
très difficile très difficile donc je
suis parti à 14 ans et demi sur le point
je lave où j'en suis aucunement fier de
redoubler pour la troisième fois ma
quatrième fallait me sortir du été
placée pour vos l'école et je suis
rentré au bozar parce qu'à l'époque on
pouvait avec un niveau
bepc
ou à peu près
rentré dans les grandes écoles si on
composait prendre des chemins de
traverse et c'est vrai que je déplore
dieu sait que la culture générale et est
formidable c'est formidable que c'est
augmenter que beaucoup de gens en
bénéficient mais pour des cas dans mon
genre spécial is able très tôt je dire
c'est c'est dommage de plus pouvoir
prendre des chemins de traverse comme ça
et accéder à des écoles qui sont niveau
universités
et puis voilà donc j'étais aux
beaux-arts je voulais être peintre et
après actrice est alors voilà il ya un
orientateur professionnels figurez vous
que dans un salon du livre là en
normandie ça ne fait que trois jours que
je connais le nom de l'orientation
professionnelle qui a peut être décidé
de ma carrière c'est à dire
rené
galy galy renégats niveau je crois au
négative on me l'a dit a dit parce que
ma tante quand elle m'a fait entrer aux
beaux arts a dit bonbons je suis un peu
inquiète quand même de le faire courir
orientation professionnelle qu'est ce
que vous en pensez et le type a dit
écoutez elle vient de rentrer deuxième
sur concours aux beaux-arts on va pas se
plaindre tout à mai mais elle lit et
elle écrit tout le temps et je me
rappelle de cette phrase extraordinaire
elle va perdre le contact avec les mots
en s'occupant des formes et des couleurs
alors pour qu'elle continue à étudier
des textes c'est issa le truc pourquoi
ou n'inscrivaient pas que ces retards
dramatiques deux fois par semaine on
dirait jamais pensé et on n'est jamais
pensé quand vous commencez ça pour vous
c'est le déclic ou pas du tout je me
rappelle pas du tout de l'entrée
non non mais non ce qui a été le déclic
en écrivant un des derniers livres que
j'ai fait sur mon parcours artistique
comme ça
gg j'ai pris conscience de ce que savait
ce qu avait été le déclic solitaire à
l'école ouais travail solitaire aux
beaux-arts chacun devant sa toile chacun
devant son truc et là au conservatoire
j'ai mes des coûts l'émerveillement des
copains des partenaires le groupe de
travail et les sa connaissance me
retiens où on va couper sa siens situe
d'affilée et ça je crois que c'est ça
qui m'a embarquée est révolu hélas
c'était ben oui c'est pour ça que je
suis une comédienne de troupes très bien
oui j'adore ça le rapport avec les
autres travailler ensemble et je crois
que ça a été une telle découverte pour
moi c'est ça qui m'a embarqué alors
c'est une chose de s'y plaire dans cet
univers mais c'est une autre chose une
autre paire de manches que de plaire
qu'est ce qui fait que vous allez être
si vite remarqué par les plus grands
qu'est ce qui va plaire chez vous c'est
votre côté solaire justement très
collectif que c'est parce que je n'avais
pas peur
comme ce n'était pas un grand désir
j'étais assez à l'aise finalement jamais
le faire mais j'avais pas
j'avais pas peur quoi du tout j'avais
pas j'étais un peu j'étais un peu pas
normal quand même et donc insaisissable
c'est peut-être ce qu'il est et j'étais
dans ce déni du deuil que j'avais où
c'était j'étais un peu avant à 20 cm
au-dessus du sol ça devait un peu un peu
un peu curieux avoir est une femme très
belle aussi qui attiré l'oeil évidemment
de ces réalisateurs c'est une époque où
on a pu considérer que les actrices
étaient aussi quelque chose qu'on
affichait une jolie chose est ce que
vous vous êtes senti parfois chosifié un
peu instruments dérivés comme une belle
voilà je me souviens très bien d'un choc
que j'ai eu
je sais où c'était d'ailleurs c'était
aux studios de boulogne à l'époque
c'était idiot cinéma a tancé sur télé et
je tournais un film j'avais fait
effectivement le cinéma m'avait un peu
rapt et au théâtre j'ai fait une
première pièce qui avait pas duré
longtemps puis et puis jouer avait
pendant un an au moins avec elvire
popesco et puis le cinéma m'avait rapt
est comme ça et puis vers je vais avoir
23 ans
voilà entre 18 et 23 ans il ya eu comme
ça beaucoup de films beaucoup de films
et puis je me souviens très bien qu'un
jour j'étais prêt d'un décor c'était un
décor à 3 d'attendre que ce soit prêt et
il y avait là
quelques mètres de moi le producteur et
le metteur en scène
et je les ai entendus dire
on en a quand même eu de la chance
parce qu'elle aurait pu être incapable
d'aligner trois mots et heureusement
elle est bien etc et comme il regardait
dans ma direction je me suis tourné pour
voir de qui parlait il ya personne
derrière moi donc c'était vous et là
c'est jeu j'ai compris l'expression mon
sang ne fait qu'un tour
parce que j'ai écouté ça je dis mais
enfin mais moi je sors du conservatoire
j'ai étudié classique j'ai eu le premier
prix mais qu'est ce qu'ils aient de quoi
iraqui parle là et là je me suis dit
mais si je reviens pas au théâtre je
suis perdu voilà j'ai pas si je reviens
pas au théâtre super dur et j'ai peu de
temps après j'ai repris la danse et
repris le chant en fin du cursus ce film
de delphine seyrig sur ces 23 comédienne
du cinéma qui raconte le sexisme les
humiliations les demandes de changements
physiques quoi tout ça vous vous l'avez
vu de loin ou votre caractère a fait
qu'on n'a même pas osé vous le dira
enfin le rouge c'est ça j'ai pas
vraiment fait attention comme par
exemple j'ai pas été sauf une fois avec
un très vieux réalisateur mais c'était
une seule fois j'ai pas été très victime
de harcèlement de choses comme ça je
crois que je crois que je faisais un peu
peur et puis et puis le cinéma des
années 70 de claude sautet yves robert c
représente aussi une époque dont
certains sont un peu nostalgiques une
époque où on pouvait fumer sur sur les
plateaux dit pas de ceinture de sécurité
santé cette nostalgie de cette époque où
on croyait on sentait être plus aya vous
savez je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
quand il est arrivé cette chose très
désagréable confinement qui va nous
faire avaler quand même une grosse
pilule qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
vous faire avaler une grosse pilule on
passe à la télé le soir un éléphant ça
trompe et gestion flyers c'est vrai nous
sommes les doudous c'est plus doux du
suspect mais quoi y'a un truc très
désagréable à un ogre et paf on colle un
éléphant ça trompe ou les tontons
flingueurs vous vous lavez cette
nostalgie de cette époque j'ai pas
vraiment nostalgie non non pas du tout
mais c'était c'était vraiment formidable
je repars l'es2 des rôles que vous aviez
joué ils sont innombrables et des
nominations aussi vous allez en avoir
pas mal 1977 vous êtes nommé pour le
césar du meilleur second rôle dans un
éléphant ça trompe énormément c'est
finalement marie france pisier qui va
l'emporter cette année là vous serez
ensuite nommée cinq fois aux molière de
la comédienne
88 pour le secret 90 pour le pain de
ménage et le plaisir de rompre 96 pour
un mari idéal 2006 pour oscar et la dame
rose 2010 pour colombes dans les
nominations n'est jamais le prix alors
c'est une bonne journaliste parce que
d'habitude les gens aiment les donnes
les molières carrément alors vous avez
eu ce non-lieu et oui non mais j'ai fait
la différence mais du coup est-ce que ça
a été une frustration pour vous comment
vous l'international en pas non
absolument pas sylvain clé les prix bon
c'est à partir du moment où je travaille
je fais bien mon métier je suis apprécié
c'est sympa je me souviens notamment
d'un d'une dénomination ou sans avoir je
me suis rassuré d'ailleurs sans avoir le
moindre pincement au coeur j'ai applaudi
à tout rompre intérêt parce que c'était
mon amie suzanne flon qu'il l'avait on
était très amis camarades
ma vie je me dis donc t'es pas alors
vous avez des ressources de la
télévision parce que vous avez eu 2 7
d'or quand même donc la télé c'est vrai
ingrate c'est vrai que j'ai jeté quatre
ah bon vous avez pas stabilisée j'avais
mes enfants petit à l'époque et ce truc
était un danger public se tenait pas
debout c'était le 7 et est pointu y
avait une antenne points c'est vrai et
comme c'était dorer les enfants riaient
l'attraper
1988 et 1993 anny duperey j'ai une
archive pour vous qui nous a été
transmise par les archives nationales
jeu la donne et vous allez identifier
très vite sarah bernhardt ce sont des
clichés de sarah bernhardt issus du
fonds d'apollon et d'une collection de
photographies rassemblés par l'abbé
misse et sarah bernhardt à qu'actrice
peintre sculptrice française du 19e
début xxème siècle victor hugo la plaie
la voix d'or jean cocteau inventé pour
elle l'expression monstres sacrés et
vous l'avez incarner cette vers le
théâtre danse arts à une pièce d'éric
emmanuel schmitt adapté de mémoire de
john murrell à l'époque les critiques
les ai relu su retomber dessus elles
étaient dithyrambiques
je vous lis l'une d'entre elles anny
duperey d'un naturel désarmant elle sait
réellement intégré ans sarah bernhardt
du travail d'orfèvre et je lisais pour
ce rôle vous aviez perdu 6 kilos en
quelques mois c'est vrai pas du tout
mais diantre faisait faux pas du tout
par contre stéphanie fanny ardant qui
avait créé le rôle et je ne veux pas
trahir fanni en disant qu'elle n'était
pas à l'aise dedans elle n'était pas
elle et elle n'était pas à l'aise elle a
souhaité le quittez donc moi j'ai repris
j'ai repris le rôle après et vous vous
êtes senti à l'aise dedans oui mais ce
qui a eu c'est que
j'ai repris le rôle en dix jours
en dix jours
et en essayant de ne rien bouger pour ne
pas troubler robert hirsch métiers
totalement fan cgtg zac très fans et on
sait magnifiquement entendu avec en
était de la même école quelque part
comme je suis quelqu'un qui peut très
régulier très très alors on est il m'a
testé un peu de temps en temps me disant
tu pourrais peut-être si on faisait ça
dans quelques jours je vais te le faire
tout de suite robert
sarah bernhardt qu'est ce qu'elle
représentait pour est-ce que ça a été
une sorte de modèle ou non sa vait pas
été une sorte de modèle mais ce lexique
c'est un personnage absolument
incroyable pour l'époque quand même elle
a quand même été joués jusque chez les
indiens en amérique je veux dire faux
fallait le faire et effectivement
c'était on le sait peu mais c'était une
femme comme ça pluridisciplinaire
comme vous l'a exhortée incroyable oui
oui mesurer disciplinaire c'est
exactement on va y venir justement vos
autres talents si on a beaucoup parlé de
l'actrice anny duperey mais moins de
l'écrivaine de la romancière pourtant
votre carrière littéraire est
impressionnante là aussi je cite
quelques uns de vos ouvrages votre tout
premier roman c'est la demie roi en 76
couronné par l'académie française
ensuite votre autobiographie le voile
noir en 92 beaucoup manqué m'amener à
l'autobiographie nous allons voir plus
loin veux-tu le rêve de ma mère le tour
des arènes aujourd'hui toujours aux
éditions du seuil que vous apporte
l'écriture de romans que ne vous apporte
pas le théâtre le cinéma le fait de
jouer d'être actrice
je crois qu'en fait là là je crois que
j'étais écrivain avant tout c'est vrai
que par exemple quand j'ai retrouvé à
quand j'ai écrit ce livre c'est à propos
du nom deuil et de la mort de mes
parents le voile noir
j'ai retrouvé dans un carnet d'enfance à
13 ans j'avais écrit où je parlais une
seule fois le mans des parents un jour
il faudrait que j'écrive mon livre en
majuscules donc ils étaient déjà des 13
en clair que ce serait pas une
psychothérapie c'était pas la mode à
l'époque
surtout dans mon milieu que je me
confierait pas à quelqu'un que ce serait
un livre que ça devrait passer par un
livre est donc l'écriture je crois a été
à la base de tout
l'écriture a toujours été et hélas vous
a aidé à commencer à guérir à 6,4 y voit
là et je crois que j'ai écrit mon
premier roman effectivement j'ai dû
recommencer j'avais 24 ans il est paru
deux ans après quelque chose comme ça
parce que ma tante a eu le téléphone
c'est à dire que je lui écrivais je sais
qu'elle adorait comme j'aime comment
j'écrivais donc je vais envoyer 10 pages
par semaine de ma vie parisienne et puis
un jour elle a eu le téléphone
perdu mon lecteur
annie du ps est aussi la photographe je
disais que vous aviez plein de monde
plein d'univers mais c'est incroyable
vous êtes photographe depuis tout jeune
aussi et ça ça vous vient de vos parents
du ceri ginette le gras qui était
photographe tous les deux alors il était
photographe mais
j'avais pas regardé je voulais pas
regarder les photos de mon père j'avais
les négatifs bien planqué là pour ne pas
les voir puisqu'il était mort je leur en
voulait beaucoup quand même et ces plans
de façon je me suis même pas rendu
compte qu'en fait j'ai je suis parti
dans la photo pour faire comme mon père
j'avais pas vu ces photos et c'est vrai
que pendant une coiffe 18 18 20 ans j'ai
j'ai fait passionnément de la faute aux
labos compris
développement même mais pellicule ce qui
pour les gens qui ont fait de la photo
se rappelleront de la cuve paterson dans
le noir total ou piquer des crises de
nerfs parce que tout à coup on entend
des skrulls
au milieu de la pellicule on avait coupé
un loupé un cran il fait le tour des
faits
c'était extraordinaire et en 2010 vous
allez vous confronter aux photos de
votre père vous allez organiser une
exposition il y aura les volets oui
c'est vrai que j'ai
j'ai eu une chose encore voilà une chose
un petit signe comme ça
j'ai beaucoup de signes dans ma vie
comme ça mon agrandisseur un jour s'est
mis à perdre le point donc il fallait
que je le refasse d'entre chaque photo
or à l'époque je faisais beaucoup de
photos de mes copains un comédien que je
donnais donc je leur faisais des vingt
des vingt tirage à suivre et
agrandisseur qui perdait le point entre
chaque tirage me m'énervait et c'est là
que j'ai pensé tiens tiens tiens si je
m'achetais un bel agrandisseur
pour peut-être développer les photos de
mon père que j'ai jamais vu mais de
quels formats sont les négatifs j'ai
tiré les cartons et puis ça a été la fin
de mon mon travail de photographe
du moins en ce qui concerne le noir et
blanc qu'est devenu sacré
j'ai des photos justement pour vous
fanny du père et que je vais vous
montrer normalement elles sont censées
vous rappeler des choses vous parlez là
c'est chatte luxe malves alex folie dans
la creuse la creuse que vous avez
découverte il ya 40 ans avec bernard
giraudeau c'est lui qui avait acheté une
ferme qui vont leur train de retaper et
puis on montre votre divorce de décider
de la racheter de racheter cette de vors
disons de séparation au séparables oui
jamais été marié de ma vie oui un peu
votre votre coin de paradis cette
creuser oui j'aime beaucoup j'aime
beaucoup la creuse l'histoire de la
creuse est tout à fait et tout à fait
formidable quand même c'est
ils ont construit paris 1 les creusois
les maçons creusois ils ont conçu
l'opéra et d'en contrôler où ils ont
construit énorme versailles 2 mais tout
ce qui est et qui avait du talent
là bas était tailleur de pierres au mas
sont
montés à paris les maçons de la creuse
premières revendications ouvrières
premier député masson martin nadaud et
donc ces gens qui étaient censés être
vraiment les plus arriérées de la terre
était dix fois plus au courant que
toutes les provinces ce qui se passait à
paris et qu'est ce qui est arrivé bas
1905 1910 le chemin de fer est arrivée
la creuse s'est vu des peuples et des
deux tiers de sa population
ce que les gars qui est monté à paris
effectivement faire tous ces beaux
monuments qu'on a là eh bien ils ont
emmené la famille les enfants voilà
c'est tout et donc c'est la creuse à une
désertification trouve que c'est une
histoire extraordinaire
parce que du coup c'est un pays c'est un
pays où on peut on peut se sentir assez
facilement chez soi si on aime la terre
sur un tas parce que tous les gens sont
toujours partie et revenue
donc ya pas de folklore bruyant ya pas
excusez moi les creusois même pas
vraiment de vraie spécialité
c'est vrai que c'est un pays comme ça et
un moment où on est dans une époque où
peut-être la ruralité est un peu oubliée
ou mises de côté j'imagine que pour vous
c'est important de parler de ce oui
c'est bien et puis j'ai puis la creuse à
un grand un grand avantage comme tous
ces pays qui sont qui sont sur les
contreforts du massif central c'est du
granit s'est pas cultivables donc il ya
jamais eu le roman brement
donc c'est les paysages de nos c'est
peut-être pour ça que je me suis senti
bien pour écrire aussi pour écrire sur
le passé c'est que rien n'a bougé c'est
le paysage des arrière grands parents
voilà et puis vous retirer de la
frénésie parisienne aussi peut-être dans
laquelle louis enfin j'ai eu longtemps
maintenant ça s'est assouplie quand
j'écris mais il ya eu une époque où
j'avais l'impression de qu' il y avait
un lieu pour l'intériorisation est un
lieu pour l'extérieur chinois pouvaient
pas qu'elle oublie que vous avez dans
cette croûte vous avez donc une maison
et un jardin un immense jardin que vous
cultivez est-ce que vous reconnaissez ce
cette plante enfin c'est je crois que
c'est là c'est la rose du père est
exactement c'est la rose du père et qui
réussit pas du tout c'est vrai donc non
l'ipad regarde j'ai essayé dans la voix
elle est dix fois plus belle chez les
autres ingrate ouais c'est derosier anny
duperey vous avez un rosier à votre nom
et une rose jaune très résistante très
par fut très parfumée c'est ce qui vous
normalement normalement mais je chez moi
elle fait
un peu la tête chez moi mais le
jardinage est aussi une de vos passions
oui c'est vraiment votre oeuvre
aimant passionnément pendant pendant 30
ans j'ai fait un jardin que l'ami
stéphane marie pour s'élança poussa un
film est très bien d'ailleurs et c'est
vrai que j'étais j'ai été j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça les armes et où je me suis
arrêté de compter 100 75 espèces
d'arbres différentes c'est pas mal allez
une dernière image à vous montrer c'est
l'association sos villages d'enfants
dont vous êtes la marraine depuis près
de 30 ans une association créée au
départ pour les orphelins de guerre et
qui s'occupe aujourd'hui d'enfants
maltraités placé retirés à leurs parents
et la spécificité de cette association
et c'est ce qui vous tient à coeur c'est
qu'elle ne sépare pas les frères et
soeurs ça aussi ça fait partie de votre
histoire bien sûr bien sûr j'ai été je
n'en veux pas du tout à ma famille parce
que quand même ma mère et mon père avait
30 31 32 ans père de deux enfants comme
ça un si beau aussi jeune
c'était terrible donc chaque famille a
pris un enfant voilà et ma soeur était
étant beaucoup plus jeune que moi mais
cinq mois elle était elle avait cinq
mois oui oui et moi j'avais 8 ans et
demi donc c'était
voilà et c'était une catastrophe c'était
ça a été une catastrophe je pense très
sincèrement que de cette histoire
ma soeur elle en est morte vraiment il
ya une très 13 ans 13 14 ans je dirais
l'a vécu le coeur serré toute sa vie et
ça a fini par l'emporter
et c'est vrai que c'était le fait d'être
séparée était une catastrophe et donc
quand on m'a proposé effectivement de
marrainer une association qui ne sépare
pas les frères et soeurs j'ai trouvé ça
évidemment j'ai été tout de suite
enthousiaste pour être pour être
marraine alors j'annonce dans j'en
profite il ya une comme à rennes
maintenant depuis peu qui est isabelle
carré par isabelle carré va être comme à
rennes des souhaits ce village d'enfance
j'en suis ravi parce que c'est vrai
qu'au bout d'un moment je disais mais
c'est un peu moi je raconte toujours la
même chose à raconter autre chose c'est
mon histoire et ouais mais surtout de
raconter rien d'autre c'est votre
histoire isabelle va va être comme à
rennes avec moi et on essaiera de
l'inviter dans un monde un regard une
dernière question anny duperey nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu ici vous
avez la sagesse ici vous avez la
prudence ici vous avez la justice est
ici vous avez l'éloquence laquelle de
ces vertus vous parle vous caractérise
peut-être au lynchage peut-être lassé
ges oui oui madame vous êtes très sain
je crois que finalement je suis assez je
suis assez sage super on s'arrêtera sur
7/7 vertus là alors merci infiniment
annie duperey d'avoir été avec nous dans
un monde un regard merci à vous et merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis comme chaque
semaine on se retrouve très très vite
sur public sénat à bientôt
[Musique]